[Music]
i'm not judging anyone
[Music]
don't be jealous
we are upping the ante
can we be on the floor oh we are
hi i'm johnny hi natasha
hey i'm billy today we're making balloon
animals
can't wait i am here to sway
so we're just gonna get started with the
warm-up
making balloon animals can be pretty
challenging it's definitely one of those
skills that you're going to want to
practice to get a little bit better at
it
it's fun it's actually very relaxing i
love it when there's 20 kids who all
want a big balloon
that takes a lot of time and they're
impatient and the secret to great
balloon animals
is sharpies and all you have to do
is add a face and it will make your
competitors
look not as good as you because their
dogs don't have little heads and faces
sorry unless they have sharpies at which
point you're just competing against
people that are
as good as you and it's not the same
does it have to look like a snail
god let me make it look like what it's
supposed to look like
[Music]
ah i have a snail with a really big head
a really long neck she is fabulous
ladies and gentlemen probably a little
too long
[Music]
the clock is ticking the pressure is on
oh my goodness
[Music]
yay mine pumped and looks great i might
[Music]
win
my snail's name is sam if i let it go
it'll fall apart
um here's my snail and this snail has a
very long neck because he likes looking
for things
and here are his antennas that are
feeling real silly
and he's got a face yeah he's got lovely
eyelashes
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls here
is
my snail fabulous
don't be jealous he's got a cute little
head over here and then this
exotic shell i'm not going to say
anything bad about the snail over there
that has mumps but i think it's great
[Music]
oh darn my competitor's balloon
popped how sad for her
[Music]
my princess is gonna have green hair
because she can do whatever she wants
the strategy going in to this
competition
is to surprise the judges i'm gonna be
showing them stuff that they have
never seen before my strategy
is to make a princess who feels good
about herself
and sure she's pretty but she's also
smart and funny
and hard working and you know she goes
after her goals
my princess has green eyes but what
would really make her pretty
is ruby red lipstick my princess
is wearing a crop top because she's a
modern lady i'm working on the face
right now
it's not really coming out the exact way
that i had it pictured in my head but
i think i'm getting close 30
so i think i might have misunderstood
the assignment
i thought you wanted me to be the
princess so i whipped up the best
princess crown i could come up with
and here she is i am ready to work the
runway yeah i'm a princess yes
you go princess billy thank you thank
you
princess crowns always work of course
they're not the princess balloon but i'm
not judging anyone
whose name rhymes with billy
i have a princess who has a side
ponytail
because the 80s are back uh she has a
crop top
uh lovely eyes and um oh look it's like
she's talking
and she has two arms and uh she may not
be wearing pants so we don't need to see
the rest of it
my princess can be like a puppet watch
do you love me
yes i do do you talk when my mouths move
yes you do i love my blue dress johnny
thank you
can i kiss you sure you're the best
clown johnny now don't be rude
no he's the best vote for jack yay
johnny i think
i think that you both won
does our dinosaur eat people or just
vegetarians he's a nice one
okay people he's people oh i was
thinking kale
kale yeah leafy greens yum
yum how about kale raptor out of caveman
yay kale get on anything though all
right keep going kids
we only have 60 more balloons to blow up
and then we have to put it together
if only there was a way to edit this
down to a section that looks small
and short yet still adorably hilarious
[Music]
i have never made a balloon animal this
big i mean
this is practically the same size as me
actually billy you broke my tongue
[Music]
don't worry about it that's what amazon
is for
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
look at the head of the dinosaur that's
[Music]
starting
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
whoopsie apopasaurus oh my goodness
oh my i'm getting a headache
the sounds you hear are clown tears
falling on the cement floor of this
sound stage
ladies and gentlemen i present a
ferocious dinosaur
[Applause]
i don't want kale
[Music]
gir oh and he makes a ferocious sound
there you go the famous very very
realistic historically accurate triangle
balloon tail
yay i think they've done a great job
don't you
i'm sorry did i hear from the crew a
round of applause
yay stop
you guys
i say perfection your thoughts kids i
think it's so adorable and it's to scale
the perfect dinosaur this is the most
delightful
torture that i've ever put myself
through and basically need to go touch
up my makeup
yay i feel real sweaty yay
and proud yeah but on the bright side
it's got macaroni horn
and look at it on the side see how the
rib cage is
literally recreated like at the natural
history machine
[Music]
a museum and look at the valley and the
tail come on
this is the cutest balloon dinosaur
you've seen today am i wrong
am i wrong right thank you right right
and look at the best part it's head
floats in the air
ooh halloween floating dinosaur
[Music]
you